world-renowned gold medalist paralympian
turned convicted murderer
are we getting breaking news coming in
from South Africa it was a shooting
incident this morning paralympic and
Olympic star Oscar Pistorius has
allegedly shot his girlfriend in 2014 he
was found guilty of killing his
girlfriend Riva steenkamp they powered
together for three months before he
fired four fatal shots through the
bathroom door in the early hours of
Valentine's Day
my daughters did our family is
devastated living without who and he's
his family's devastated
the 50-day murder trial spans seven
months and was the first to be live
streamed in South African history
a media spectacle
I am warning the media if you do not
behave
you are not going to be treated with
soft gloves by this court heavily
compared to O.J Simpson's 1994 Hollywood
murder trial
foreign
Pistorius testified that he believed he
was shooting at a potential Intruder and
the defense made a virtue of their
loving relationship
but the Smoking Gun was literal
the judge found him not guilty of murder
but culpable homicide with a maximum
sentence of five years the verdict was
widely contested and appealed twice by
the state it was eventually upgraded to
murder he was sentenced to 15 years
imprisonment by the Supreme Court
Pistorius was first released on parole
in 2016 but that too was appealed he was
sent back to prison and now he faces the
parole board again upon calculating the
time that he had spent all the time that
he spent in
incarcerated was taken into account and
that is why his application for parole
is ripe to be heard now
if he's successful in convincing them
that he should only serve half of his
sentence then he'll go from a prison
cell in one of South Africa's most
notorious maximum security prisons to
living in his uncle's mansion in
Pretoria if not he's back behind bars
until the next hearing
[Music]